il faut savoir encore sourire
bon le meilleur s'est retiré et qu'il ne
reste que le pire
dans une vie bête à pleurer
il faut savoir courte que coûte garder
toute sa dignité
et malgré ce qu'il nous en coûte s'en
aller sans se retourner face au destin
qui nous vous des âmes
et de bas
à la bonne heure il nous faut savoir
cacher c'est l'homme
mais moi mon coeur je n'ai
m
[Musique]
il faut savoir quitter la table
lorsque l'amour et des célèbres
sans s'accrocher l'air pitoyable
mais partir sans faire de bruit il faut
savoir cacher sa peine
[Musique]
s'ouvre le masque de tous les jours
et retenir les cris de haine
qui sont les derniers mots d'amour
[Musique]
il faut savoir rester de glace
était un coeur
qui meurent déjà
il ne faut savoir
car déjà poste
mais moi
je t'aime trop mais moi je ne peux pas
il faut savoir mais moi
je ne sais pas
[Musique]